Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain an American science
fiction action film called “John Carter.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie starts on a strange planet called
Barsoom. The planet consists of three major
kingdoms called the Helium, the Zodanga,
and the Tharks. Helium and Zodanga have
been at war for centuries.
At the beginning of the movie,
we see the army of Helium, in blue capes, battling
the army of Zodanga in red capes. The general of
Zodanga named Sab-Than, is approached by three
men who claim to be messengers of God, called
Thern. The Thern’s leader, Matai Shang, gives him
a mysterious blue weapon and tells him that he has
been chosen by the goddess to receive it. The
Therns have decided to help Zodanga in the war.
They possess control over a mysterious blue light
called the ninth ray which makes them stronger
than other living creatures on Barsoom.
The scene cuts to New York City in 1881.
A man named Edgar is summoned by his uncle named
John Carter to New York City. When Edgar drops
at the station, he is greeted by John’s butler,
who takes him to John’s estate. As it turns out,
John is a wealthy man and a former Confederate
army captain. John’s lawyer sadly informs Edgar
of John’s sudden death. John has left all of his
numerous wealth to Edgar. The lawyer then takes
a surprised Edgar to John’s mausoleum, where his
body is being preserved. But strangely, the door
of the mausoleum only opens from the inside.
Later, the lawyer hands Edgar a personal diary of
John, which John wanted only Edgar
to read. When the lawyer leaves,
he starts reading it. It begins by mentioning
that Edgar was the only one who believed
John’s wild stories when he was little, so it
only feels right to tell this story to Edgar.
The story starts in Arizona after the civil war.
John Carter is a former captain in the Confederate
Army, who currently looks for gold in caves.
Powell is a union colonel who wants John to help
his U.S. cavalry soldiers against the Apache.
So, he abducts him and tries drafting him as a
soldier. However, John doesn’t want to fight as
a soldier anymore. After several failed attempts
of running away, he manages to escape by knocking
a guard out and stealing the colonel’s horse.
The colonel and his men pursue him. Not far away,
they come across a mounted Apache war band. The
Colonel and the men get into a shootout with the
people. John tries running away amidst the chaos,
but the Colonel gets injured in the fight. He
helps the colonel out of pity and brings him near
a cave. The cave is new to John as he has never
come here to search for gold. He goes inside,
lights a match, and is beyond surprised to see
lots of gold embedded on the roof of the cave.
However, just then, a man behind him appears out
of nowhere. The man is one of the therns we saw
in the beginning of the movie. The colonel alerts
John, who gets into a fight with the strange man.
He shoots the man, making him fall to
the ground. When John goes near him,
he hears the man say “Barsoom” while looking at a
strange medallion in his hands. John picks up the
medallion and repeats the word, Barsoom. Suddenly,
a bright blue light flashes out of the locket.
When John opens his eyes again, he is in a strange
desert. He gets up and tries walking, but falls
in every step. It seems as though he can float
mid-air. Confused, he practices walking in the
new environment. As he walks, he reaches a hill
nearby where he sees several eggs hatching.
Just then, a large group of green creatures
with six limbs appear riding on massive animals.
The leader attacks him, making John take a huge
leap. The rest start firing at John, but stop when
their leader asks them to. The creature speaks in
a different language and introduces himself as Tas
Tarkas. John introduces himself as John Carter
from Virginia, but the creatures decipher that
his name is Virginia. Tarkas asks John to jump
as he did before, but he denies and attacks him.
The creatures injure John and hold
him hostage. As they talk, we get
to know that their kind is called “Tharks”.
Elsewhere on the same planet, the princess of the
city of Helium, Dejah, practices presenting
a weapon she has designed to her father,
the king of Helium. Helium is at war with another
city called the Zodanga and is about to lose
because of Therns being on Zodanga’s side. Dejah
has figured out the secret of the ninth ray used
by the Zodanga to fight the war. However, when
she shows her weapon to the king, a man secretly
causes a malfunction causing it to explode.
The king of Zodanga, Sab-Than,
wants to marry Dejah for the war to end, but she
is extremely against it. If Sab-Than marries her,
he will be the prince of Helium and will
have the power to rule all of Barsoom.
Meanwhile, the Tharks take John to their
city and put him with the newly born infants.
At night, a female Thark named Sola feeds John
a liquid, after which he can understand the
language of Tharks. The following day, the Tharks
order John to jump high in front of everyone.
John notices that the medallion is with
Tarkas and without it, he cannot go back home.
Just then, two battleships appear in the sky. The
Helium and the Zodanga are battling each other.
The war is entertainment to the Tharks who bet on
who will win. We see princess Dejah fighting in
the ships. She tries to control the ship but falls
off it in the process. John, using his newfound
jumping powers, saves the princess. The Tharks
start cheering for John who is now fighting the
Zodanga’s soldiers along with Dejah. John manages
to change the course of the fight, making the
Helium win, but their ship crashes as well.
Dejah and John are with the Tharks. Tarkas is
impressed by John's abilities and makes him his
right-hand man. John is reluctant to the idea, but
doesn’t disagree. At night, Dejah and John talk,
and Dejah reveals to John that they are on Mars,
which is called Barsoom in their language.
John is surprised and doesn’t believe her.
He tells her that he is from the earth. Dejah
too finds it hard to believe. Because of his
thicker bone density and the planet's low gravity,
Carter has incredible strength and can leap high.
Dejah then takes him to the Thark’s
temple, where no humans are allowed to go.
She hopes that the temple has a way to know how
people can travel through worlds as John did.
The kind female Thark, Sola, goes behind
them begging them to stop. Dejah shows
John the statue of the goddess Issus, and
reads some markings engraved in it. However,
the three of them are soon arrested by the Tharks
and sentenced to death for entering the temple.
Tarkas asks everyone to leave him alone with the
prisoners in the cell in order to cut John’s hands
off. When they are alone, he reveals that he
is Sola’s father and doesn’t want them to die
at the hands of the Tharks. He hands John his
medallion and asks him to go to the river Iss
to solve the mystery of the goddess
Issus and get back to his world.
When the Tharks look into the room after some
time, they see that Tarkas has betrayed them.
Tarkas’s enemy, Tal Hajus, takes charge and
declares himself the new leader. Then we see John,
Dejah, and Sola heading to the river Iss. Dejah is
leading the way, however, Sola tells John that she
is leading them towards the city of Helium instead
of the river. John confronts her about it, and it
turns out that she was taking him to her city to
use him as a soldier in the war. Disappointed,
John asks Sola to lead the way and leaves the
princess there. Dejah insists that she only did
it because she doesn’t want to marry Sab-Than. He
asks her to accompany him to the river. With no
other way out, she agrees. The three sail through
the river of Iss and reach a massive inverted
pyramid. John and Dejah go on top of it and see
a strange blue energy forming on the ground.
Dejah realizes that this is the power of the ninth
ray that she had made her weapon from. They also
realize that Carter's appearance on Mars is likely
due to the transmission of a copy of himself from
Earth to Mars, with the help of the ninth ray.
Just then, an army of Warhoons approaches,
led by Matai Shang, the leader of the Therns.
John bravely tells Dejah and Sola to run away
and fights the army of Warhoons himself.
The king of Helium sends his army to John's
aid who defeats the Warhoons and saves him.
They take an injured John to Helium. Dejah
reaches her home and meets her father. She
is surprised to see the king of Zodanga,
Sab-Than, there. He has come with no weapon and
soldiers to ask Dejah to marry him and end the
war. Dejah doesn’t have any other way to stop the
war, so she reluctantly agrees to marry him.
In the following scene, we see John resting in
a chamber in Helium palace. A soldier appointed
by Dejah fetches him and secretly takes him to
her chamber. Dejah asks John to go back to his
home using the medallion. When the guards enter
her chamber, John disappears. Dejah thinks that
he went back to the earth, but John is hiding
actually from the soldiers. When they leave,
he tries going outside but is soon caught by Matai
Shang. John is surprised by Matai Shang’s ability
to change into any creature around him.
The whole city is preparing for the wedding
of Sab-Than and Dejah. Matai Shang binds John to
himself with the help of a technology developed by
the ninth ray. John is unable to move his body to
his will. Matai Shang seems to be controlling him
with his wrist device. Matai Shang then reveals
to him that Sab-Than is planning to kill Dejah
and invade Helium after the marriage. The Thern
took his side in the war because Sab-Than was the
easiest to manipulate. But Matai Sang’s real aim
is to rule all of Barsoom through Sab-Than.
Matai Shang is about to kill John, when
an alien dog John had befriended earlier,
comes to his rescue. It bites off Matai
Shang’s wrist device letting John free.
He hurries to a flying craft and flies away to
stop Dejah from marrying Sab- Than. However,
John doesn’t know how to control the aircraft and
crash lands near the Thark’s territory. They hold
him captive with a beaten Tarkas. Tal Hajus, who
is now the leader of the Tharks, puts John and
Tarkas with massive beasts called the white apes.
John somehow manages to capture the apes in front
of the whole Thark population. He then invites
Tal Hajus to fight him and defeats him in one go.
Everyone cheers for John who is now the new leader
of the Tharks. He then persuades them to help him
fight the Zodanga. The army of Tharks and John
make their way to Dejah and Sab-Than’s wedding
ceremony. John reaches there just in time to
stop the wedding. Seeing him, Sab-Than tries
to kill Dejah but John stops him just in time. A
war between the soldiers of the two cities erupts
again. However, the Tharks are on the side of
Helium now. The Zodanga soon loses, but Matai
Shang manages to escape with John’s medallion.
John plans to live on Mars as Dejah’s husband
so he doesn’t bother to look for the medallion.
He and Dejah get married and the crowd cheers
for them. He is now the prince of Helium.
The following morning, John and Dejah are on a
balcony. Dejah leaves John outside and goes into
the room, when Matai Shang appears. John tries to
fight him but he manages to use the medallion to
send John back to earth. When John wakes up, he
is covered in dust and his beard has grown long.
He is in the same cave, and looks towards Colonel
Powell to see his remains, suggesting that a long
time has passed in the earth while he was on Mars.
He looks around for a medallion but
doesn’t find it. He has no way to go back.
The gold embedded in the cave makes him wealthy.
He knows that there are more medallions on earth.
He starts a mining corporation and searches for
the medallion for the next ten years. Until one
day, he finds one on a site. John is delighted
but he knows that the Therns have been keeping
an eye on him all this time. His body on the
earth must be protected when he goes to Mars
because any harm on it will cause him to die on
both planets. That is why his mausoleum only opens
from the inside. He had orchestrated his death
to return back to Mars. John writes in the diary
that he wants Edgar to protect his mausoleum
from the Therns in turn of the wealth.
Edgar is in shock after reading the diary. He
goes out to the mausoleum and tries opening
it with a secret password which turns out to be
‘Ned’, the name John called Edgar when he was a
kid. As the doors to the mausoleum open, a Thern
approaches Edgar. He had been spying on Edgar,
waiting to kill John. However, before he can
harm Edgar, someone from behind knocks him out.
Edgar is beyond surprised to see his uncle in
front of him. John takes the Thern’s medallion as
it turns out, he had never found the medallion.
All this, including his death, was faked to
attract a Thern and acquire his medallion. John
then asks Edgar to protect his mausoleum from now
onwards and goes inside it. He lies on the bed
with the medallion and says the chantings that
will take him back to Mars again.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank you for watching.